ويمكن ان تنتقل الكاميرا يعني ترينا بعض
الشظايا التي وقعت هنا ومعنا ايضا عمران
وهو احد
يعني اقارب الضحايا هنا يمكن ان يحكي لنا
ايضا القصه كامله عمران يعني اين ومتى وما
هي الاثار التي ترتبت على سقوط هذه
القذيفه هنا في حي الشرفيه
السلام عليكم
زي ما شايفين اثار الوظيفه
الحيطه والمنزل جوا
والجيران وعندنا جوه في المنزل اثنين
شهداء بنيه وولد الولد عمره 26 سنه
والبنايه
عمر 11 سنه
والبنايه ضفد او امبارح هدف امبارح
شايفين الحمد لله ربنا يجيب العواقب سليمه
وربنا يحفظ الجميع والحرب ده ان شاء الله
يا رب يا اخي ينتهي في اقرب فرصه ونتمنى
يا اخي يقعدوا في طاوله ويتفقوا لحل الوسط
والشعب السوداني زي ما شايفين الناس
يطلعوا الشارع يشوفوا في الشارع لانه
والله الحال
يعني امبارح جينا الوفا ده الشارع في نهب
وفي حاجات ما قدرنا نقعدوا
[موسيقى]
الاوضاع الامنيه عموما كيف في منطقه
والله الاوضاع الامنيه كويسه لكن السوى
الشعبي جوه يعني ما بتلقى زول ماشي بيدينا
العشره اي مواطن شايل له مشاهد السكينه في
يدينا
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات